[Musik]
weiter schwere unruhen in den usa
proteste und gewalt die sechste nacht in
folge nach dem tod des afro amerikaners
george freut
zurück zur neuen normalität wie läuft
der tourismus in corona zeiten auf den
deutschen nordseeinseln und trauer um
einen ausnahmekünstler die kulturwelt
würdigte christo den mann der welt
berühmt wurde als er den reichstag
verhüllte
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster es ist pfingstmontag guten
abend und herzlich willkommen die
unruhen der tod von george floyd vor
sechs tagen überall in den usa ausgelöst
hat scheinen kein ende zu nehmen
der afroamerikaner war bei einem
brutalen polizeieinsatz in minneapolis
ums leben gekommen
doch trotz ausgangssperren gehen seitdem
die proteste gegen rassistische gewalt
weiter ihr motto black lifes matt
schwarze leben zählen eines damms
berichtete das weiße haus über stunden
belagert von demonstranten die
bürgermeisterin von washington hatte
eine ausgangssperre verhängt und
sämtliche soldaten der nationalgarde
mobilisiert dennoch konfrontationen
zwischen demonstranten und polizei viele
schreckt das nicht demonstrieren
funktioniert so beendet man rassismus
martin luther king hat es getan und man
hat ihm zugehört inzwischen hatten wir
einen schwarzen präsidenten proteste
bekommen aufmerksamkeit proteste
landesweit in mehr als 30 städten fahrt
gehen einige polizisten vor aber es gibt
auch gesten der solidarität polizisten
fallen aufs knie übernehmen damit die
geste der schwarzen gegen rassismus
wir haben sehr chaotische nächte hinter
uns deswegen bin ich aufs knie gegangen
wenn ich damit frieden vermitteln kann
falle ich jeden tag aufs knie erneut
kommt es abseits der demonstrationen zu
plünderungen und sinnloser gewalt unklar
wer die aufrührer sind sind des
antifaschisten oder rechtsextremisten
für präsident trump scheint die sache
klar
obwohl belege fehlen ich sehe keine
anzeichen dafür twittert ramp das weiße
rassistische gruppen mitmischen dies ist
die antifa den gouverneuren der
bundesstaaten hat trump heute geraten
härter gegen gewalttätige demonstranten
vorzugehen
auf eine grundlegende botschaft des
präsidenten an ein aufgewühltes land
wartet man bislang vergebens auf eine
botschaft die brücken baut
doch trump setzt aufspaltung auch in
dieser krise der teufel sitzt auf der
anderen straßenseite sagt der schriftzug
an der kirche gegenüber vom weißen haus
aufräumen nach den protesten der nacht
das land ist zerrissener denn je immer
mehr länder lockern ihre krone maßnahmen
in der türkei gibt es seit heute wieder
inlandsflüge restaurants cafés und
sportanlagen sind wieder offen
in england hat für zwei millionen
schülerinnen und schüler wieder der
unterricht begonnen was dabei unter
anderem die lehrergewerkschaft für
verfrüht hält
und auch russland lockert und das obwohl
landesweit die zahl der infektionen
steigt nur in den usa und in brasilien
sind noch mehr menschen an cholera
erkrankt aus moskau berichtet für begann
darauf haben sie neun wochen lang
gewartet
ihre buchhandlung in einem moskauer
hinterhof hat wieder geöffnet
als die stadt ende märz die geschäfte
schloss um das virus zu stoppen
verkaufte maxime seine bücher verstärkt
über das internet
die verluste durch corona sind trotzdem
erdrückend damit unser laden überlebt
habe ich mir nur zwei wochenenden pause
gegönnt sonst war ich immer unterwegs
habe bestellungen ausgeliefert von früh
bis spät gearbeitet ich habe mich noch
nie so viel bewegt wie in diesen zwei
monaten
russlands wirtschaft ächzt unter dem
strengen
wohl ein grund dafür dass jetzt
lockerungen kommen obwohl es nach wie
vor rund 9000 neuinfektionen täglich
gibt in moskau sind die zahlen deutlich
gesunken die brandherde liegen
mittlerweile anderswo zum beispiel im
nordkaukasus wo ende der woche
medizinische hilfe aus der hauptstadt
eintraf
wir haben behandlungs routinen
entwickelt auch für sehr schwer
erkrankte und wir hoffen dass wir
unseren kollegen mit dem was wir gelernt
haben helfen können
während dem kaukasus das schlimmste
vielleicht noch bevorsteht atmen andere
teile russlands auf drei mal pro woche
dürfen die moskauer nun spazieren gehen
ich hoffe dass die quarantäne bald
beendet wird und wir ruhig spazieren
gehen können ohne daran denken zu müssen
wie viele menschen schon gestorben sind
und wie vielen das wohl noch bevorsteht
die kleinen moskauer freiheiten sie
kommen auf probe in zwei wochen wird
bilanz gezogen dann will die stadt über
ihr weiteres vorgehen entscheiden
ein blick auf die entwicklung in
deutschland da ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen mit dem chor ohne virus
wieder gesunken
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage steckten sich täglich 440 menschen
an
insgesamt registrierte die johns hopkins
universität seit beginn der pandemie
mehr als 100 83.500 infizierte davon
gelten mehr als 165.000 als genesen 8500
46 menschen sind in verbindung mit cupid
19 gestorben
die wirtschaft wurde von der korona
pandemie hart getroffen morgen beraten
daher die spitzen der regierungsparteien
über weitere maßnahmen die konjunktur
wieder in fahrt zu bringen
die positionen liegen allerdings noch
weit auseinander
gestritten wird unter anderem über eine
kaufprämie für neuwagen und die frage ob
sie auch für benziner und diesel gezahlt
werden soll
eine weitere idee ist ein bonus für
familien mit kindern dazu jetzt
zugeschaltet gunther love energy in
berlin
das klingt nicht gerade nach einer
einfachen entscheidung wer streitet denn
da wofür also auf den ersten blick wirkt
das war
klassisch die union fordert die autokauf
prämie die spd fordert den familienbonus
aber wenn man dann etwas genauer
hinsieht dann sieht man dass die fronten
gar nicht so klar sind beim
familienbonus gibt es zum beispiel
applaus von csu chef markus söder und
auch armin laschet
nrw-ministerpräsident sagt das ist doch
eine tolle idee warum nur 300 euro wie
die spd das vorschlägt man könnte doch
auch 600 euro an die familien aus zahlen
also da zeigt sich dass in der krise die
interessen vor ort die bedürfnisse in
den regionen in den vordergrund rücken
und die decken sich eben nicht immer mit
der parteilinie das wird das morgen hat
keine ganz einfache verhandlungen bei
diesen punkten
das ist auch nur einer unter vielen
punkten es gibt noch eine ganze lange
liste und ein großer schwerpunkt der
morgen auch gesprochen wird ist die
entlastung von kommunen die in dieser
krise sehr gelitten haben da gibt es
einen vorschlag von olaf scholz
finanzminister der sagt wir müssen da
bei dir bei den altschulden run der bund
sollte die kommunen entlasten die union
legt jetzt einen gegenentwurf dazu vor
da gibt es auch noch sehr viel
diskussionsbedarf und wahrscheinlich
konflikte morgen das ganze geht um 14
uhr los und wir hören jetzt schon von
allen beteiligten es kann sehr lange
dauern mindestens bis in den abend
vielleicht sogar bis in die nacht der
blick auf die neue woche in berlin
vielen dank und ein staatliches
rettungspaket für die lufthansa aber nur
unter auflagen
nachdem vorstand hat das nun auch der
aufsichtsrat der schwer angeschlagenen
fluggesellschaft akzeptiert damit ist
ein weiterer schritt getan für
staatshilfen in höhe von neun milliarden
euro
die eu will dass die lufthansa im
gegenzug einige start und landerechte an
konkurrenten abgeben in frankfurt am
main und münchen über die vereinbarungen
soll ende juni die hauptversammlung
entscheiden bundespräsident steinmeier
hat sich bei den kindern bedankt für ihr
durchhalten in der korona krise zum
internationalen kindertag sagte er im
kinderkanal kika ihr konntet freunde und
verwandte nicht besuchen nicht zum
spielen raus ins grüne kitas und schulen
waren geschlossen
er finde es aber klasse dass sie sich
trotz alledem so gut an die regeln
gehalten hätte
in der zdf- heute- app gibt es das ganze
interview in dem der bundespräsident
auch fragen von kindern beantwortet und
sich auch bei den eltern bedankt es war
ein pfingstwochenende wie aus dem
bilderbuch fast überall sonnenschein und
sommerliche temperaturen
klar dass es da die menschen auf die
nordseeinseln gezogen hat in zeiten von
corona eine ganz besondere
herausforderung die zurückgewonnene
lebensqualität genießen aber trotzdem
immer schön abstand halten meistens hat
das geklappt anselm stern berichtet
ausspannen abschalten es ist die lang
ersehnte erholung vom alltag der virus
krise pfingst frei sonne corona
lockerungen all das macht vor allem gute
laune bei den strand touristen und auch
bei vielen insulanern wie hier auf
norderney
die meisten oder neuer sind natürlich
froh dass es wieder losgeht und die
kurgäste sind auch sehr zufrieden meinte
ich dass die also sehr positiv das
betrachten auch die abstandsregeln
werden zum tag gut eingehalten
maske abstand urlaub mit corona regeln
bis auf ein paar ausnahmen scheinen sich
hier die meisten brand zu halten
wichtig etwa für die insel restaurants
die so dringend angewiesen sind auf das
geld der gäste wir hatten ja geschlossen
gar nicht meine mitarbeiter habe ich
jetzt alle aus der kurzarbeit wieder
rausgeholt sind alle wieder dabei bin
hier auch ganz froh drüber und wir
hoffen natürlich dass es so wie es jetzt
ist noch ein bisschen sich steigert sagt
thomas fischer er meint die zahl der
kunden denn die ist noch weit weg von
normal auf den allermeisten deutschen
nordseeinseln ist tagestourismus noch
verboten
im gegensatz zu manchen ostseestränden
die lübecker bucht hier der timmendorfer
strand heute extrem voll zu voll wegen
überfüllung geschlossen hieß es dann
mancher orts am nachmittag sie ist eben
anders diese urlaubszeit mitten in der
virus krise
seine werke waren nie für die ewigkeit
gemacht trotzdem sind und bleiben sie
wohl unvergessen
auf der ganzen welt vor
handelte christo öffentliche räume in
kunstwerke in dem er sie verhüllte
imposante gebäude landschaften derart
eingepackt machten er und seine frau
jeanne-claude aus dem schönen das
geheimnisvolle besondere wie hier in
berlin der verhüllte reichstag nach 20
jahren überzeugungsarbeit 1 2 wöchige
besuchermagnet nun ist christo im alter
von 84 jahren gestorben
aus seiner heimatstadt new york johannes
hano voller tatendrang hat er uns noch
anfang märz in seinem new yorker atelier
sein letztes projekt vorgestellt
die verhüllung des arc de triomphe in
paris die aktion musste wegen krone auf
september 21 verschoben werden
christopher lee bob team ist auch nie
war die menschheit enger miteinander
verbunden
ich denke das ist fabelhaft auch wenn es
viele probleme mit sich bringt wie diese
krankheit die jetzt umgeht aber das
miteinander ist nicht zu stoppen
er war der superstar der internationalen
open air kunst mit viel geduld für
projekte die kaum länger als zwei wochen
zu sehen war 25 jahre kämpften er und
seine frau jeanne-claude für die
verhüllung des berliner reichstages wie
bei vielen seiner projekte gab es
zunächst massiven öffentlichen
widerstand doch es wurde schließlich zu
einem monumentalen spektakel mit
menschen zusammen brachte und das
deutschland mit anderen augen auf sich
selber schauen
mit seinen verhüllungen ging es christo
eigentlich immer darum dinge zu
enthüllen um so ihre schönheit zu zeigen
linke inseln in florida oder der
verhüllte pomp in paris
christo und jeanne claude war nichts zu
groß unsere projekte sind völlig
irrational völlig sinnlos einfach nur
kurz christo in bulgarien geboren floh
1957 in den westen in paris traf er
seine frau und partnerin jeanne-claude
sie starb 2009 gates im central park
waren das letzte großprojekt das triste
zusammen mit ihr realisiert meine werke
existieren nur diesen kurzen einmaligen
moment und verschwinden dann für immer
wie unser leben
doch für die millionen von besuchern die
christus und jeanne-claude kunstprojekte
erleben durften bleiben sie
unvergesslich und zum schluss noch das
eigentlich ist richard wagner ja bombast
und ganz großes orchester nicht so in
corona zeiten
vorhang auf heißt es da in wiesbaden für
etwas weniger wagner mit kaum
instrumenten
denn es gilt abstand halten auf der
bühne und im publikum passt irgendwie
zum opern stück auch tristan und isolde
werden getrennt was alle verbindet ist
maximale musik unter minimalen
bedingungen
[Musik]
zur maximalen sonnenwetter mit minimalen
einschränkungen es bleibt erst mal
sommerlich nur sehr vereinzelt werden
die quellwolken größe und es drohen
schauer
die temperatur erreicht 21 grad in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen und 30 grad am
niederrhein
das war's für heute danke für ihr
interesse
marietta slomka bringt sie später um
drei viertel 10 auf den neuesten stand
morgen freut sich an dieser stelle hier
christian sievers auf sie ich wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen sonnigen
pfingst abend